what's up fool podcast was so full
podcast
Rodrigo Torres right here yeah man March
of Rizzo's back people by popular demand
they want to know why his fingers always
smelled like cheese burger from
McDonald's but his dogs love of me hey
dogs love cheeseburgers
Lisa Esparza right here on the Wheels of
Steel over there ever people shout out
to my right there man doing everything
yeah I guess
Elinor here all the way from The Comedy
Store we go way back wait what's up bro
with all this Nationals with independent
oz is homo erotic celebration bro
[ __ ] put it in a champagne
bottle under peanuts and squirting their
friends in the face dawg and then and
then they're [ __ ] squirting each
other more and somebody is talking and
somebody gets right on top row it starts
pouring out of war they start humping
each other bro really bro that's the way
we're [ __ ] celebrating now bro
everybody [ __ ] helping each other and
that's the case but you know what I'm
glad the Dodgers lost with [ __ ] people
celebrate like that two men with no
cameras there was no [ __ ] people
wearing goggles so they won't go blonde
super ugly [ __ ] wearing ponchos
and [ __ ] but they will get wet so I'll
be killed when a Dodger won the World
Series in 1988 [ __ ] out whatever that
guy in from [ __ ] HBO he was silent he
was there interviewing everybody right
double prank Globo they were [ __ ]
squirting here with [ __ ] champagne
[ __ ] your beers well there were drinking
beers Budweiser hey let me tell you man
everybody was already [ __ ] up [ __ ]
Tommy Lasorda was throwing up in a
bucket bro
you passed out ball to the whole world
series bro
they wrote weekend at bernie's because
of him there was only one reporter two
reporters and they will walk into the
winners and [ __ ] you know they get alway
with champagne oh man what's it like to
be a winner it's very slippery boy your
life bro we want to thank oh man God
brought us here and so [ __ ] happy man
yeah you know and then after that bro
let's go over there to the Yankees you
know they Lars right and they have to go
they're all wet wrong the walk of shame
like smelling like champagne like
they're wet brother buzz and I gotta
talk to the Yankees blow their terrible
lost so I was back to him bro it was
tough but now they have two reporters
they got one over there was a sad one
losers
haha the Dodgers and the homoerotic guy
that was at school you knew each other
in her face the Dodgers had a kleenex
party that was painful
that hurt huh yeah
I was furious I mean obviously I wasn't
rooting for the Dodgers but I didn't
have a dog in the fight but I was
watching I was like I got that reader
feeling my heart
yeah my nephew plays for the twins oh
yeah he he's in their farm system but
he's been in there for like two years
three years now so hopefully he'll come
he'll win he'll be home oh and out there
watching it go down baby if you're
watching it live you know that the
astronaut gonna play the Yankees today
yeah and I think that Yankees are gonna
not go anywhere because they got around
Spike Lee and Nick totoro curse you know
more than the front row Nick's
crematorium and the gang they're gonna
win and make your tools stay that
homework or watch it on television they
win wrong haha I'm gonna show up at his
house you're there with Wesley Snipes
brother
our scripts do the right thing to put me
in the movie come on Joe Torre's hat you
got much original hair bro you don't
like EA Sports no I know I know I mean
no I do like sports I live by Dodgers
staying for two years out uh yeah I do
they wouldn't let you in huh do ya I'm a
bad boy
I live the block away from me and like
during the games they would just Park in
my parking spot it was that bad yeah
they don't care I'm same thing with
Philly like when Eagles play my mom's
neighborhood they try to steal our
parking we just go ahead I was trying
over parking do they try for over chub
people who are parking in neighborhood
too yeah you know we used to doing where
our kids this was something stupid but
like there was a public school and I had
an empty school yard so we would charge
them to park in there yeah you were
there almost the same time yeah it was
cool where do we hang on I forgot you
can come to my neighborhood but no we
were pretty much this around where the
city right we went to the park and we
went down to the Bell one day and that
was it real quick
our American roots the Liberty Bell oh
yeah that little dog part a little
little tiny part and then what adved
City Grill three times good did you go
to the Reading Terminal no we went
someplace called hit hip city bad you
know like vegan chicken sandwiches what
are you gay being a Philly cheese with
the Nationals were I have you been vegan
2011 yeah oh I'm so sorry
yeah it's all good well Chris
cheesesteaks and like the Knicks in the
Reading Terminal saga like
pork with broccoli rabe that's where you
get it yeah okay I mean but in Center
City otherwise you'd have to come down
our neighborhood or just venture out and
that's everybody South Philly
cheesesteak that is those two guys they
make a vegan now too though because my
niece is ving him on and off what would
you have yeah but I've been eating less
meat for the last ten years not as much
cut down for about 40%
you know opposed to like everything meat
you know when I go to Philly though I do
notice I eat a lot more like red meat
like every meal has like bacon or very
hearty food yeah meatballs and you're
just like like I leave have to detox for
like two months W grew up in Philly
South Philly yeah from South Philly
right I believe so who is he yeah he's
the dope dealer part care with Toby
hates black comedian oh yeah I know Toby
yeah yeah here enjoy more have a podcast
shut up - Toby hates his birthday he's
available Saturday October aches now he
was canceled did you why do you get
canceled to say something no man he
can't cancel my date Tribble no you know
he had a gig Bob Raquel here a gig and
it fell apart so you'd open now oh I see
the best of us numeron millions that but
sometimes matter if you're lucky they
cancel the show and they say here the
whole bunny - oh that's amazing
one time it was Bob it was a guy named
mom mark Babbitt oh [ __ ] this used to be
the manager the laptop
I remember him I remember his name
because of Freddie SOT oh yeah Jodi I
said Joe the first the first time I
heard of him because Willie Barcena was
working with mark Babbitt at freddys
Thoreau and and
Joe Diaz and just the everybody came
back as the Abra he was all over the
owner bro that guy you're calling him
that he's a legend oh no you're a
[ __ ] legend much better much better
you're a [ __ ] legend wasn't who you
you still would have never done what it
did man you stole our company here in
evangelism for the dog I started in LA I
started at The Comedy Store which is
weird after waiting tables for like 12
years at The Comedy Store you were
waiting tables with Terry right Terry
Clark yeah sure it was my waitress yeah
I was Mitzi's personal assistant for
years I just I never was interested in
comedy but Friday was my best friend
Freddie Soto and when Freddie passed
away it just I don't know [ __ ] me up you
know it just changes your life you start
thinking like what are you doing but
every day Friday we'd be like you should
be doing stand-up you're an idiot do
stand-up you were always talking [ __ ] to
people always holding court in the
kitchen at the store shutting people
down if people like a lot of times like
I just saw Ari Shaffir up there Ari
would [ __ ] with my waitresses and I
would just go in and school him while he
was on stage and the audience would be
like who is that like just some crazy
angry waitress leave oh I'll leave my
waitress alone because I was stand up
for them sometimes they would call me
Norma Rae oh no I look like that all
right [ __ ] sometimes you catch a glimpse
you're like is that Caitlin
oh but yes so after Freddie passed it
was just like this is your life and at
the time I was engaged to dice so I
brought my lovely uh my second ex-fiance
he hates when I say that but but yeah so
I broke up with dice I just everything
just got weird for me where's the
diamond
oh I gave it back I gave it back to him
he goes no you keep it I go Thanks
thanks for the memories buddy so have a
nice old were you still waiting tables
you had no no wait I had quit the comedy
store I was gonna move to New York and I
remember Freddie and Cory were pissed
like don't move to New York you know and
so I was moving to New York and Andrew
and I had broken up then we got back
together right before I was leaving he
proposed and I was like he proposed at
the Comedy Store it was so bad
like I had a full room I had a full room
in the belly room it was packed and I
had just put all the drinks down and I
went downstairs to pick up a corona to
bring upstairs and he asked me in the
kitchen I go I gotta bring this corona
out wheels he did get wheels to ask me
out in the beginning and I was so pissed
he's all mafia-style I was like [ __ ]
that girl for you hey I told you who
shiny checks you know go away
you could do wheels I'm here we'll
hopefully base wise this guy's
inevitable turns my phone calls
oh yeah called you last week
shifty [ __ ] responsible for your
career a million people a million people
I'm like no you're not wholly not
responsible for anybody's career what my
route was Vegas
yeah no I live in Florida we torture
wheels but I love wheels but he's wheels
you know when he came to me and he was
like dice wants to take you on a date
I'm like go [ __ ] yourself don't come at
me like that like what are you talking
about yeah if you're a man talk to me
you know I'm like oh you know just
respect doing Joe Pesci and Reggie boy
I'll tell you hit with my car I took
that little finger for ferry want to
talk to you it he's still not over that
I keep telling him the brain smell right
so I saw Ford Fairlane at heart and I
was a kid I loved the theater and people
in line were doing the whole dice thing
really I was in the theater I was in one
weekend and then the gay mafia got him
thank you they pulled him out yeah
wasn't like Gloria Allred saying oh yeah
it's hate Mouse clothing comedy she
would be amazing but the other the the
bigwigs in Hollywood were the ones that
were like hey cuz other studios were
like we're not working with you if you
don't pull this film he's he's a gay
basher
we bout to do what women this is back
then and there yeah it was whoa quick or
what he said in a movie or we could set
off stage both a little bit of both in a
movie huh I don't know yeah walk back
darling yeah bad oh I like that you call
it whoa progressive
oh we're aware I don't before so us up
away well they were they were just like
looking to hurt him so they basically
left him for dead like Holly would just
turn her back on him there no studio
would work with them cuz David Geffen
was like if you work with him we're not
working with it you know they were all
going against him because though they
had no choice
these were the guys that ran Hollywood
because I always hear that like you know
I was back there you know you could say
stuff like you know what guys was saying
back in 80s but I heard that people were
still but he was the catalyst like they
were like you're so right yeah he was a
whipping boy for everybody yeah did you
watch a documentary on Netflix a hip hop
it's called the I forget exactly what
it's called but it's basically like how
hip hop started the evolution of hip-hop
evolution of hip-hop yeah yeah
why couldn't I think evolution my brain
is dead anyway I haven't evolved yet but
uh of the evolution of hip-hop there was
some about 2 Live Crew and they were
comparing him to dice and I was like
wait what but okay but yeah it's true
like all those Richard Pryor they would
say it and to Live Crew came out and
they got like they also were big
catalysts for getting in trouble for
speaking you know freedom of speech
basically because I always hear people
say oh I've married children came out
today people go crazy by her that people
are going yeah you just we don't we
don't hear you didn't hear it as much
back it wasn't people there's more
hush-hush it just went away and then
then the general public would be like
hey what happened to you and you're like
what do you mean what happened you
didn't feel that like but they didn't
know now they're like oh I know what
happened to him
I saw like because he did a live stream
of it this is what they did to me or
people are voicing their opinions on the
internet or not letters you know you can
continue the argument or the controversy
for years yeah but that's funny he said
letters my favorite thing at the Comedy
Store to do was we have a giant file
cabinet or we've had no of hate mail
over Paul Mooney yes and it literally
was like a filled and I was like Paul
you need the publicist you would we
would have to keep it aside cuz it took
every drawer did he read this no I did I
just had my
freedom Oh the white lady is trying to
bring me back
what does white little hands face those
white little lips just wash my check
[ __ ] tell me what's up I love horny
bring that bag time at Laugh Factory
when I worked in a factory all these
people had left the show like right in
the middle of his set they walked out
angry yeah yeah they were roll overs
from the ten o'clock show and I was like
midnight you know he was just sitting
there up on the stool all quiet but he
said something I can't remember what his
statement was and he came off stage I
said you know you were right that makes
a lot of sense and he said at least one
of you was listening I don't know man he
remember when went to the comedy store
the day or the day of 9/11 that night oh
you remember what the marquee said I
don't remember what the marquee said Wow
that's what she put on the marquee I was
like man I can't put yeah she goes just
put it up there just wow I know that
we're being attacked on American soil
she's like yeah Wow he was on stage the
entire time because we're worried about
and I'm quoting here folks the land
[ __ ] didn't worried about the same
[ __ ] clearly left no running out I
couldn't believe what he said I'm so
happy like Def Jam II don't really go in
the comic stores on no nights but they
were a lot of them were there well we
were the only ones that open right to
bring it on outside no it was all like
peeking through the little steps right
there yeah one of my favorite Haman
Holtzman would always like whatever
tragedy they would just take it I'm
wrong with it like during the Oklahoma
City bombing Holtzman was like yeah they
said some kids got killed
yeah well whatever bad kids they didn't
put the head down to her nap time they
were they were drinking the chemicals
under the sink I'm like what people
freak out like that
Holdsworth of beds but that's the beauty
of the store which I always love this
like Mitzi would put these crazies on
that no one liked Robert a purveyor
Robert William a perv oh yeah every
night he was like when Robin Williams
came back he was like oh my god that guy
still here he thought he was seeing
things
Sara freaking out he was like no no that
guy can't still be here and then just
the other night Damon Wayans was like
hey does that Robert William a provide
so come here I'm like oh my god I can't
believe you remember him but yes but
Mitzi used to give him bus fare because
she felt bad because he was like a
really big lawyer or something and he
had like a breakdown
yeah and just lost it all he obsessed
over was Johnny Carson but he wanted to
replace him like he was okay yeah can
you imagine oh my god he calls dombarris
a naughty like every night good do you
remember him yeah of course like napkins
napkins in his collar
he was afraid of the universe oh no I
was the one that went not the dice man
and some wheels and some guy that works
with my dog in I forgot his name the
Todd the time-bar dog they put all the
chairs and Finance oh you won't be able
to get off the stage
oh my god yeah I [ __ ] with him Todd
would wear sweat pants in a suit jacket
you're like why no like we can't just we
can see your bottom when you're todd
it's the greatest his I had a baby said
his dog one night he was on stage he's
like he can you watch the dog on my
claim the Todd he had that dog he always
brought bark dog was his name yeah and
so I had to go to the bathroom and I
went into the main room to use the
bathroom it was closed naturally because
back then I was like dead and we were I
went in the main room the dog went in
with me and she was it freaked out
ran all the way down Sunset
it was some kind of ghost or something
that spooked it out yeah a lot of people
ask about the holiday store in the
hunting of it so the dog got spooked
right in that wreck the [ __ ] out I was
like oh my god I just lost Todd's dog
and I'm yelling down the street like
bark dog and they're like you can't yell
commands at it and I'm like no no that's
its name bark dog I'm just trying to get
it bad I was the one that went to go up
and it was like 1:30
and I went up I would let the send me
potluck when they put your name in a
little bit of pickle jar oh yeah
and they do it there Todd was he the
host I think so no late dude it was
really late and ever going home and
falling asleep and he was 1994 and in
the [ __ ] I'm Nora
oh absolutely right and you know who
closed out that night Carlos Mencia yeah
and I was pissed cuz when I went home he
was on HBO his half-hour and I was like
a rock haunting me and I finally fell
asleep and then it woke me up
we were some everybody in a stables
talking about how creepy that night was
yeah how much there's something's gonna
happen like a weird weird vibe yeah the
weirdest comics the cup the last cup or
five comment was in the main room I
remember I didn't get home until about
3:30 like in Dennett that's what I'm
saying I fell asleep watching Carlos and
then if I can hit CSUN earthquake or Big
Bear one of those Northridge CA
Northridge yeah yeah
I never heard of Northridge until that
day and you go well that's why my ex is
from Atwater right here yeah okay yeah I
like Atwater that's a nice area the cute
rocking in and everybody that I make we
had played jokes
mooney with the glass remember he would
take a Santa Fe glass like cognac glass
and just like oh you were rocked on
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah my ex grew up in Atwater and
everybody's like oh is he one of those
gender fires I'm like no he's old-school
everyone hates him cuz he didn't like
fix up his house you know he just left
it I was even i water back in the days
man I remember in school old school man
when it was still there already of state
trying best I'd live in there allowed
transgender ladies and I looked I came
out of my house cuz I live right there
my up my single then I was living with
my son's mom and my my son little a
studio but then we moved across the
street to the one-bedroom but but a
liquor store I saw a transgender man get
person asked I said she was in the
street and then somebody pulled over got
out of it to just appear at well got
back in the mom got robbed like that to
man and my neighborhood was dying of
AIDS bro and he was reading just baby
foods and you knew he's gonna be leave
he gave me all the baby food for Phillip
oh we were like his only friend I pulled
a alone door like we were the only
friends here a young young boyfriend but
it would always fight you know drama but
then he'll ever there was a lot of gay
people who live in that area in that
neighborhood I was living there in the
90s yeah they were all dying do those
sad like life yeah sad no that's what
same room Aaron yeah like 92 right yeah
you and the Beastie Boys living right
there yeah cuz they recorded right yeah
that's right on the corner where my back
flip so he'd be like I'm like alright
calm yes no I don't but he live around
there yeah good there's a throne and
that one on Brunswick there's two homes
they look like they look like they're um
they were not like bedrock little a bit
yeah
interesting yeah yeah I think I know
that was hell yeah I know what you're
talking about that's funny but his is
just like you know everybody else like
built up on it like bought the property
cheap and built up you know but he's old
school like still fight with Frogtown
and [ __ ] like just does a guy that
though living there when I was living
there but he now you know he's in prison
doing multiple life they call him the
Atwater monster
what and that guy was like three years
Oh execute bro that's a double negative
remember that that that student got
robbed and someone was killed at that
studio my only worry ya know was that
yeah oh [ __ ] he was a little fun that
gang in that water was a beast
yes yeah to nerville and that was the
thing for the Warner Brothers without
water rascal or at water somewhere mmm
wasn't that called too Norville cousins
animators yeah that's insane yeah
there's some dangerous like it was a
dangerous area yeah I mean I like it
though I like our water
I like that element of it more make me
feel more comfortable
yeah it's too bougie and it's too
transient so Hollywood to you these days
it's awful they closed Highland today
just in case you're wondering is it a
Burbank to kill everybody
honest to god I get I get close hi
little wife construction or concert
Kevin Hart
pick on everybody but really I like it
he's a North Philly kid yeah I don't
know they just did do that they closed
freeways like I remember driving home
from La Jolla one night they're like all
the tens clothes I'm like you can't just
close it that's what happened what they
do how do I lose my [ __ ] man I have no
patience because I'm Philadelphia
they'll drive through construction no
[Laughter]
Versailles left Riverside the other day
they had closed the 60 on right oh
that's better get on to the 60 from and
we had to go all the way over when I
catch you saw I forget where we went we
ended up on the ten we had to drive
locally and go get on the test so gross
right yeah like we drive locally for yum
yum donuts
Yeah right there that's off the la
cadena you stop you can't um yum donuts
you eat vegan donuts yeah no they're
good
oh yeah I had on voodoo donuts in
Portland a couple weeks ago damn good
like cereal on top it was like a little
ghost and it was black and I hate this
[ __ ] oh that's the other big in place a
donut friendly yeah strawberry shortcake
peanut butter and jelly that's who again
my mommy's make donuts at home no what
is she a magician cookie dough la broke
you out yeah people fry them in the pan
the Bisquick
all right there was Bisquick and they're
like she brought your sugar it's like
sugar doughnut do you make Cronus
[ __ ] greasy with full of sugar I like
yeah yeah that's just pure yeah well
good like the little bit quick little
round one maybe she got you know a
flower and they just like make the
doughnuts and fry them and I okay Wonder
Bread doughnuts right Wonder Bread toner
I was like I was obsessed with doing it
because my daddy's always give me when
shows a year I tell people a story yeah
basic base to meet up like right there
like mid-city my mom my dad cuz you were
giving like the cows support that's
where the transfer happen yeah the
traffic city was with those big
Victorian houses okay no that is but I
remember I remember [ __ ] they will
leave me at my mom and my in my dad's
truck they would give me like a bag
doughnuts and they would go into my
mom's car and I remember like seeing
them like doing this yeah I swear to God
yeah yeah they would do their stuff
because you know that child support was
like transactional and he had to
supplement the luggage why do you have
another family at the time was he trying
to get a discount
I mean he's making doughnuts oh so you
wanna cover something yeah I don't know
they're doing I just saw they're just
don't know well I was okay so I was the
first family and then I so how became
the side family he had like a second
family I got the motors on the other
yeah another family grew up with cable
huh so this was once a year we're doing
it regularly it was it was once a month
a one-meter yeah yeah yeah it was I
remember only like a couple of times
number one time we went to like a Motown
I was a little kid and I'm like go play
games buddy
every time it would turn off the TV it
might allocate a magazine he was trying
to hug my mom why are you trying to turn
it off and I get I cry again so I watch
TV but there is so little I trust people
that parents didn't split up they deny
it
wait why'd they split up her mom his mom
like refuses hey my mom was taking my
dad's Social Security and they were
split up for years with my mom had ten
kids and they my dad left when I was
like seven deserves it yes well if he's
not gonna pull out he's just gotta leave
but she can't afford a divorce so she
didn't get a divorce for years and she
was like you know what I'm gonna take
that social security month that's my mom
think she is doing and meanwhile my
dad's working under the table no he's
gonna book some 1:30 bye dad he stinks
my I got married my parent ever marry
brain I remember I was little I thought
that you got to be married to have kids
and my grandmother so I mean we got
married I was crying I don't get it
are you Catholic yeah practicing no just
ask unconfirmed I did all of it i had a
stand for all i had a stand for freddy
and corey cuz neither one of them were
confirmed and they wanted to get married
in a Catholic Church
so Friday's like and Johnny Sanchez he's
like you're my godmother I'm like you're
crazy responsible for you like because
they weren't confirmed so they needed
somebody
Johnny was standing for his niece or
something and then Freddy and Cory
needed to do the sacraments because they
didn't do any of them I think they only
have were both baptized I mean II think
I made by magician yeah I know I was
like I was like they may Freddie
disappear as [ __ ] up I know it's like
I'm not Catholic and we don't have we're
not getting married by a priest and we
never visited any priest I think we're
technically married in the eyes yeah
well you did just like justice and a
peace or something he was like a
minister but you know here's our gain
but it wasn't a religious ceremony he
get ordained or something online and he
did it that's how it goes yeah do you
know that re got married in the belly
room yeah of the comedy story very
severe I'm sorry marry a long time ago
oh and Mike black married how crazy I
mean is set up for disaster
getting married on a comedy club
yeah Jamie kept telling us to get
married that laugh factor it's like I
know what this place looks like with the
lights on yeah those are comics Gary
Glitter's married Marty Moreno and a
lady at though I saw I saw the bro
Bob Fisher was the best man that's like
TV shows when like the casanare leaves
like the seti and they be get married
there I get the office or something like
that so what how long have you guys been
married
this will be our fifth year of marriage
1234 ember we've been together go for
this will be our 13th year together
right yeah Marcin looking for an
apartment in that video bro that one bed
you want man I was private the thing I
got a oh [ __ ] somebody put a bunk bed on
top of a bath tub warrants and
Philadelphia no kidding I was I was I
was getting a lot of trouble in Philly
like a lot of fighting and then I moved
out here and they don't fight out here
it's a very strange town allowed to hit
anybody
yeah they all have so but no yes that's
exactly what it's so bad but I when I
moved here I wanted to be an actress
and it was like 1993 and looking for a
job looking for a job the only job I got
was at the Comedy Store so I was like oh
just stay here these guys seem [ __ ] up
like me so I stayed there for 12 years
but I was trying to be an actress and
then auditioning auditioning getting
nothing getting engaged ruining that
moving on and then I became a wrestler
no I'm not that old
Wow women wrestling I'm out oh my god
Wow yeah mm I still do commentary for
them they're great they're still on
there on access TV now yeah I hear think
dice was like you just got to get on TV
you got one more thing and then you're
gonna be huge and I'm like okay thanks
and I go you know I'm on TV every Friday
night
what where's this channel I hero and
then last night he found it and he goes
did you know Wow
because I do commentary for them some of
the girls still wrestle that I wrestled
with but I don't have the hips for that
like it'll just break you know and
they're my age and I'm like well one
girl she's Colombian her name's Erica
Porter she's phenomenal and she plays
jungle girl but she still flips around a
gym we're the same age like made out of
something different I'm Irish we break
my hip is going as we yeah we brought
from the inside out not good not good
don't know don't do it I need to go to a
like acupuncturist or get the stem cells
stem cells the injection and I kill her
no no you're gonna go to El Salvador
then which like I don't think it will
help cuz my joints yeah we're all good
but that's what he got these Jordans the
stem cells in his shoulder and his fine
what went out of the country to do it
yeah I had to do that with Mitzi - yeah
she got my thing God has done in TJ that
fix the shoulder opposed to surgery with
stem cells there's nothing but Europeans
and Canadians right there at that office
and TJ get nah it's a medical tourism
absolutely because you have prosthetic
like we went to Dominican Republic mitzi
and I to do
she got stem cell injections and it
would it don't cure her disease but it
slowed it down like it was a little late
the first time she came back she was
great the second time it was a little
sluggish but it was scary for me because
it was like weekend at Bernie's you know
I'm like this [ __ ] dies you know it's
gonna be bad how am I gonna prop her up
for Paulie so you don't matter
you know like and then we love my mom ya
know Paulie but I remember not cool yeah
right I remember she was like laying on
the bed and this abandoned Hospital in
Dominican Republic
I never been out of the country you
don't I mean so this is like crazy for
me and I'm sitting there signing up
paper says if she gets sick then I've
gotta treat her in the United States and
I'm like oh [ __ ] so I'm freaking out and
then the guy puts the injections in her
and she looks at me and she's like I
hope that one has blond hair and blue
eyes like people are like Oh MIT sees me
I'm like Mitzi's hilarious like you guys
don't know her what year was this 2001
somewhere around the know could have
been 2003 because I wasn't wrestling at
that point when I was wrestling and
being her assistant I will go to the
house I'd have like a black eye I'd be
all bandaged since she'd be like oh
honey who did this no no I'm wrestling
she's like tell the truth I'm on your
side we did 38 until year later but yeah
the wets came early right somebody's
like he beat you up in those videos cuz
around those times in the early 2000s he
you got he was recording like a crazy
girl my way [ __ ] face yes he was going
through a divorce and so he would change
all the lighting in the comedy store he
was bought it was going crazy we have a
big-ass [ __ ] puto
Pierre has callate the white Escalade
good job yeah and the big Bronco yeah
the Bronco Buster yeah he loved that
much of the horrible dystopia - man bro
whoop dirty toe I love you
give him a doughnut run down the drain
because that show that that
documentation ended up being the show on
vh1 right yeah yeah because that's what
he was you come in you watch the kid
maxi's off I don't want that kid over
here max he's creepy but she doesn't
think about reality shows like we we
pitched it a certain way right and then
they come in they're like we want to do
this isn't it and they're like Andrews
like I'm never doing that like and they
made him do a lot of things you want to
do I mean he did it cuz like I said
Hollywood left him for dead but for the
most part he was like this is not what
we wanted to do when they didn't reopen
he was like okay like he gets happy when
they don't pick up his show was a good
show really it was him being how he is
you know to an extent yeah but they were
controlling him and he's like I wanna do
this and then they were like no so
that's what he's trying to do with these
videos the way he likes to do it I don't
know if it's gonna work but people like
them do page them I wish people helming
mad occasion from another no no you were
right to the gate oh but here's the
thing I booked the travel a lot of times
cuz dice is like you do it you know what
I like I'm like I hate this [ __ ] job
cuz if it's wrong he flips out go get
one get to a hotel and he'll be like who
picked this I'm like no and then he
leaves he leaves he'll tell people their
hotel [ __ ] we walk out I'm telling
Howard Stern I'm like wow like crazy
[ __ ] right so I when I book I get
panicked and I booked and I had a
problem with the first class so when
they booked when they said Andrew my
heart fell off a silver stain and then
he's like I don't have my status he
looked at me he's like I don't have a
seat
I thought of a seat you're you're in
trouble and I'm like
so I'm like getting beat up as we're
walking all over and then when he found
out it was you guys he was like cause
mother like he still thinks about he's
gonna come out okay
you're not gonna get it today maybe not
tomorrow but you're gonna get cuz I
think what he says he loves to prank
people and I loved but I was like carbon
to hanging out yo Hughley was there Bob
Bernal with it again so he comes up to
us but he's all like well these Mexicans
are big today what are they put it in a
burrito fertilizer but usually kind of
you usually he's the one that like you
know oh they get a little big up closer
he's [ __ ] with a legend he his
ex-wife was Mexican Mexican Italian and
Jewish Oh is that original one Trini no
no she's Irish okay it's old-school yeah
that was the second wife there was a
first one she was a farmer everybody
between New York and LA that's what she
was but it's somewhere in the middle and
for like two weeks she made him go to
this farm and that's where he gets all
that material from so that weight on it
was so real was calling the people in
Middle America farmers because what's
the name David Letterman would have put
him on so he called him a farmer and he
just went off yeah and Leno - they used
to hold that power over these guys and
and if you were any kind of like like a
lot of people are like oh you're dirty
just like dice you know you you tell
dirty jokes on my cat who cares I curse
I say a dirty thing why is that a
problem
you know what I mean they're like no we
can't book you on our shows on my we
know how to clean it up we're not idiots
though yeah like we get our audience we
know what we're doing you know and
they're like no but for years they would
[ __ ] with him yeah we're gonna put you
on no we're not going to put you on you
know
I forgot the guy's name Jim McCauley
maybe they used to book the Tonight Show
and he used to [ __ ] with people like
that
so he never got on Kinnison was never
gonna get on heating and when Kinnison
finally they finally led him on he asked
for all his people to be on with him and
they did a skit he was like [ __ ] you
guys Howie Mandel talked about that too
they wouldn't let him on he tried like
eight or nine times and they kept saying
no and then the next time he was on he
was sitting on the couch as a guest like
he was like I've never been on doing
yeah he was like and he said if there's
like I've never been on for stand-up
here like I think yeah and it crazy
they'll always do that to me like you so
dirty like I won't take it anymore cuz
I'm I get pissed out they and they made
me showcase they wouldn't let me be in
jfl for because I was too dirty then
they were like hey we have a dirty show
a showcase for the dirty show like okay
so I showcase for the dirty show they're
like you're not dirty enough I'm like
you should all kill yourselves all to
die like I was so mad and then Andrew
was like [ __ ] those things those
festivals aren't really okay I'll go by
your crazy laws but all right I'll play
a game but it's true and then like Nikki
Glaser who's a great friend of mine and
funny comic they can't put her out
enough and her show is called bangin
like the whole joke I mean the whole
thing is about [ __ ] and I'm like you
don't get any dirtier than us they can't
stop putting her own Comedy Central and
I love it I'm glad I'm just saying it's
yeah it's [ __ ] up it's like whatever
they want
maybe I'm just to Caitlyn Jenner looking
I don't know
Mickey's hot I guess I'm not good at
being a hot girl dirt dirty mouth I
don't I don't know I just feel like
today you know it's harder because they
don't accept it somebody said last night
oh I thought you're great I thought you
were just a potty mouth I'm like go [ __ ]
yourself but I guess that makes me a
potty mouth but whatever you know what I
mean it's just too much like I I don't
know I I hate the judgement to people I
mean you're not a dirty comic right but
black I see that well now a woman could
be
dirty like her they don't like it but a
guy will go off she's too dirty but the
last thing you had the last feature you
have was dirty or dirty man yeah yeah
yeah I'd rather have a dirty guy go up
before them or before a dirty chick
because it's like not ladylike in there
or something lady likes out the windows
she's dirty but they said those old like
mentalities you know or it's like yeah
but if a guy goes on before a guy like
he says and the guy's dirty why is it
that okay but a girl it's not acceptable
I don't know it is a pain in the ass I
just I'm better at hitting people then
arguing I don't know how to use my words
but I have six brothers so I don't you
know any mean like I grew up not knowing
I was a girl you're the baby I'm number
eight it's ten of us and four girls and
six boys and like my mom had four boys
in a row and she was like praying for a
little girl and then I came out butcher
and then all of her like throwing a
football I lost my tooth and I think I
was in 3rd 2nd or 3rd grade playing
football and it got jammed it never grew
back and then when it did it go straight
out laughs so that was gorgeous like if
people see pictures of me when I'm
younger they're like did you have down
syndrome I'm the beater of downs I'm in
the books it's so crazy but yeah I mean
like so I grew up rough like that
talking like that like and they like
when hear the penguin dice and I broke
up no one took it harder and my brother
Johnny
he wasn't gonna be related today it's
like awful it's a terrible time you know
I just lost Freddy my grandma passed
away like crazy [ __ ] like I'm going
through crazy I go to my brother
Johnny's just to relax with his
daughters and stuff hang out forget
about life for a while he goes where do
you see this and he puts on dice rules I
go what are you doing he goes no the
impressions at the end the girls love
them I'm like we're not watching dice
roll
I'm trying to hide here like here the
background fifteen thousand rhinestones
on my leather jet
top outer world ma as I'm like this is
ridiculous my brother's crying like I
can't believe he's not gonna be my
brother-in-law didn't idiot his
headlights oh my god like it's a good
thing we're still friends where my
brother would probably stop talking to
me me and Andrew I mean you know II mean
like he so gets excited like hey uncle
dice is coming I'm like he's not their
uncle you gotta let that go so you guys
start saying were you a comic had you
started comedy when you guys broke up
well that's it yeah it was after gross
2007 Freddie passed 2005 and so it was
like a year and a half it was February
2007 so but like I said Freddie would
always be like you should be doing
comedy the comics at the store would
always did you know and I even if the
when I was wrestling yeah the only
reason they hired me I'm scrawny they're
not like oh she's gonna be killer I
would talk [ __ ] that's all so I would
talk trash in the ring and they loved it
they were like oh this is great so
that's what I was hired for you know and
then um so I was basically doing comedy
even when I was doing that but I didn't
know I mean I I knew I was goofing but I
I would never consider myself a stand-up
because I respected it so much I worked
for Mitzi I watched the best comics in
the world come through there you know I
mean like we did Richard Pryor for a
year Robin Williams I met every comic
you could think of that came through and
just worked out like unbelievable so
when I started doing stand-up it was a
one-woman show talking about my crazy
family and then dice came to see it and
he was like you doing stand-up stupid ha
ha ha and he was with the girl that I
hooked him up with because that's my
favorite thing to do when I break up
with a guy so come up with a different
girl
so they become somebody else's problem
[Laughter]
yeah so but he um yeah so he was like
come on the road with me and I did three
months in the nerve of me to go on the
road with Dice Clay no material wasn't
tough it was the worst
I got booed off stage Big East Coasters
days already on the west coast our show
was still on the dice undisputed the
reality show on vh1 it was still on and
Andrew goes just go out there they're
gonna love you they're gonna know you
from the show you're gonna be great so
when I went out I heard somebody go
Eleanor and I was like and I do like my
little seven minutes whatever that I
prepared and it went over great in on
the west coast we did two shows
Wells Fargo it was like 2500 seats or
something like that and then my first
show three months and then 1100 the next
night I'm reading somewhere it was like
a parking lot and then they turned it
into a show and I'm like this is insane
and the sound went out for an hour so by
the time I went on I and and I was
rubbing Freddie solos picture this is a
great wheels moment cuz I was nervous
and Andrews like if you don't want to go
on you don't have to go on I'll still
pay you I'm like no I'm doing this you
know and I'm rubbing Freddy's picture
and wheels came behind me and he goes
even he can't help you now but then he
kept you on then I went on but no I went
out and I did okay that night dice went
on they were wasted by the time he got
on some lady threw some a drink at him
there was a fight broke out it was crazy
so then we go to the East Coast and at
this time myspace was big they cancelled
the vh1 show so we weren't on anymore
dice was doing is myspace story nonsense
like just like Instagram but whatever
but it was funny but people you know
kind of he drew in this younger crowd
you know all these young kids were
coming to see him and it was the
weirdest thing and I was the
theater-in-the-round in Long Island
Westbury have you ever done that one
there's like 20 I believe you we told
her we have folks really ask him I whip
it up right now I wish she was there
would I ate all my feelings that high
because it was well I went out well
first he had two veteran comics go out
like that have been with him for a while
they got a boot to but not wheels no no
is um Don Jamieson they don't care Don
Jamieson and this other guy Eric McMahan
they didn't get booed they did okay but
fights broke out the ones he dies that's
exactly they took an intermission at the
worst and then put me a lie right there
and and and Andrew was like you gotta
start dressing sexy on stage I'm like
wow that's good no he's like wear like
short shorts and high boots show them
your tough attitude I'm like that's not
my tough attitude that's my genitals
there were some glows with know where
you're wrestling now I figured he knows
about costuming so we I go out there and
he's big glass and I had this cute
little top on with a half raw and I
start I say I'm from Philly right and
they go boo Billy stink you know their
sports nut so I'm [ __ ] angry right
and they don't know that I'm a crazy
person that likes to fight so they're
like boo and I they go where's dice and
I'm like he's up my ass you want to
tickle his feet oh they went like like
got matter like I was [ __ ] on guys
hahahaha and then my sister drove like
two hours from Philly oh so shy I
remember like I locked eyes with her in
this crowd of people and she stood up
and she was like what do you want to do
want to fight this whole [ __ ]
audience oh I just remember her put her
arms like what do you want to do and I'm
like oh my god me and my sister are
gonna get a fight and it just made me
laugh and then I closed my bra slid down
and this note looked like I had tumors
on my stomach
they just kept booing and I kept trying
to do my act and they were like no [ __ ]
I freaked out but I got off and then
Andrew went on he had the best set of
his life cuz he was so mad and then he
didn't bring me out for about a year
after that because he was like see if
you're serious about it so I really I
had a rien if you will a year later but
it took a lot like that beating [ __ ]
me up that was like you initiated me now
[ __ ] that sounds crazy i'ma run this
gang watch no but it was that bad that I
was that mad every time I go to Long
Island I go with like a vengeance I'm
like I'm comin in [ __ ] like I get mad
but it's great now I still haven't been
back to Westbury but someday especially
if you bring up sports you forget yeah
that's all they care about like like I
said when the Eagles won my whole
neighborhood went crazy and then my mom
came to see me perform and I did a dirty
joke and she got mad at me she made me
go to church on Super Bowl Sunday a mile
from Eagle Stadium and one of the altar
boys the priest called him out he was
like he's wearing a Patriots jersey
under his altar boy uniform and the
whole church started booing him this is
great it's a real church sacrifice the
same yeah I bet I feel like la they
don't get as passionate about the sports
I mean I saw you crying to extent we
have a lot of sports teams you know
they're not winning dude that's what it
is oh yeah we leave early to Philly
always tell when the Eagles and the
Phillies like you'll just pan up and
they're like empty like you idiot the
Dodgers get seven runs like they're
losing seven zero by third inning I'm
gone by the force really Oh see you're a
fair-weather I start I started like
watching like okay that's like so the
brilliant pictures I never heard of now
fair-weather it's just also like I know
the traffic is gonna suck right here and
I can't even and most people sing loss I
don't want to sit through a loss and
have the drive you gotta be a hood rat
you got to just be able to walk home you
are a remarkable play most parts of it
are you used to walk a lot Felipe around
LA where everywhere everywhere I don't
have a car the bicycle yeah I remember
Freddie had this postal van that didn't
go in reverse and one time he got into
an accident the guy was like hey can you
back up he's like I can what's up fool
ya Bob Instagram yeah EJ Kerrigan and
your podcast right they do the Comedy
Store podcast yes thank you for doing it
yes that was a fun one cuz my favorite
thing he said we were talking about this
guy Davy Wester and he couldn't remember
his name and he goes he's the guy that's
like crooked he's from Washington yeah
he's great Davy he's been killing it
he's been really kicking ass on stage
and I'm bill your's you know Westbury no
no in Richland part of the bar yeah but
Bellevue Bellevue where's that to
Seattle oh oh yeah
he's like a hillbilly it's hysterical
yeah Billy who showed up by Brian Figaro
Brian Figaro Oh
he for Philly and then um wasn't it was
the night before PJ PJ yeah he came to
see me in Atlantic City me Andrew and
Roseanne school yeah that tour mr. and
mrs. America tour I was killer and you
did that one show and somebody played
baseball at the Mets play oh we did
cyclone Stadium yeah yeah with dice yeah
that was killer that's a Mets minor
league ball club yeah you giveaway was
gonna rain or not that day huh who told
you that's got Montoya watching the show
oh they sure to document Gina that
everybody happens he dies right I would
like a coming home yeah it was in
Brooklyn like it was like 40 old guy who
never go out I'm gonna go out for a
first time and they're dressed like the
last time they went out yeah yeah yeah
thought the medium of Manhattan here
yeah the big like they're talking you
could hear like on the side like he's
worried about everybody I said where was
the rain only person worried about it
was Scott McCoy that's why I asked you
because you're the buyer all right right
so it's pouring for the key you know
Mary Scott said put the camera on a
[ __ ] clouds yeah
well Scott was like hey should we cancel
and I'm like oh god this is the East
Coast cuz they comin right everybody had
Poncho's on like this our trail was
nervous he didn't have a plan in case it
rain no that's so LA on the East Coast
we don't do that we still come out
yeah and it's open yeah so it did stop
raining like by the time we saw that was
one of my favorite shows ever my hair
just looks shitty
just so human and I got curly when it's
me
it looks wild so but I just I remember
one of those pictures right before my
hair looked real nice and then I was on
stage and all this one looks like a
muppet
but I love that show did you go to it no
no sorry
oh you just saw it on TV yeah cuz you
put it in the beginning of the special
right yeah for show time everyone
thought wheel somewhere in the interview
bro they were heckling him or doing
something naturally anything you see was
part of a bird car though a mammoth cone
he makes all kinds of [ __ ] what are the
words when you leave with your part of
I'm part of pop culture no he said I'm
pop culture I'll punch him right does he
do comedy yeah well I wish I went with
wheels and this fool [ __ ] is wait
with all day long Momo as bad as we
talked about him sneak it in everywhere
to a better room with the lady from Guam
that the cashier named mmm-hmm and then
totally then like somebody he's Italian
first of all so you better soprano yeah
and I've been like seven episodes and he
lied to her I killed your now bro he
tore that up
oh yeah lie to her brother surprised you
didn't say I'm doing the spin-off the
baritones which is what he told
Sebastian Maniscalco the Verret that's
what he did yeah I mean he was so
naughty Sebastian believed he told his
parents he's like wheels is gonna get me
on the baritones this is when Sebastian
was no more you could Google stuff I
wish I was good Jimmy enjoy do you enjoy
the first one at the second one well
yeah oh yeah they're not to like what
number 21 no I think yeah they used to
put it on Craigslist hey we're
auditioning and we wanted to submit da
my rare and dice clay just for like to
see if you bring them in
yeah cuz your Dom never saw them and
they were up late night at the store and
they're doing their thing and then he
was like he got Mike Fay vermin and they
went up as the Jewish team boy and they
did the same thing but all Jewish jokes
South Philly and West Philly what's the
name bro Schubert to it too bit Schubert
ya know if he's feeling right in the
corner with my father
hey yelling I'm a magician Jimmie are in
my pan I love to bit Schubert that's my
booth what Fuli updates coming up uh
yeah we're not Detroit this weekend -
Andiamo just one show with dice then I'm
going back to the east coast we'll be at
the stand in New York I forgot parks
casino may be with Jimmy Schubert and
actually December 4th
me and Jimmy are gonna co-headline I'm
very excited about that - Philly kids
just shut Jamie shoe boy he's got to
open up for Russell Peters yes
and me and all my rare are doing helium
in Philly over Thanksgiving
yeah what's up boo I'm a beer San
Antonio next week October 26 tobin
center second show at it be there
San Diego California November the second
at home free by the bay if you can't get
tickets to that show rent a boat and
watch it for that ha ha ha West Jordan
Utah
what's up West Jordan over my garden
Landing I shouldn't be West Joe okay
Jordan landings wise guys comedy club
Modesto California member 15 at the guy
your theater the galloped in Bakersfield
California November 16 Fox Theater Napa
California shout out to Steve Danner and
itlay they're gonna show up Uptown
Theater November 22nd Seattle Washington
November 23rd Neptune theatre Spokane
Washington November 2nd at Bing Crosby
Theatre Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Andy
Warhol theater
the [ __ ] a black the black [ __ ] of
Negro League Hall of Fame Museum is
their
California Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
What did he say that anyone any Warhol
Museum is okay I believe though theater
do November 2nd November 29th through
December first Pittsburgh improv the new
and improved Pittsburgh improv they
fixed it up and then finally the guy who
fixed it up he's somewhere being the
manager and a big fine restaurant like
chick-fil-a what Starbucks ELISA will
you wet dog tonight we're at the
Paramount anything we're gonna teach you
next month again I hope so yeah almost
you coming to Portland right in the
December 13th yes which one Portland
Revolution Hall gonna be me yeah after
my birthday and I check out people's
jokes on him he was Joe with the Isaac
[ __ ] Martinez on his comeback tour Oh
who's gonna prop him up bro his Walker
what's up fool chili dog the Comedy
Store regular yeah I'll be there this
whole weekend no way after Detroit
Thursday and Friday I'm there tonight
Saturday and Sunday we saw Tom papa and
dump and watching kira soltanovich
that's a big difference without doing
while doing my celebrity sightings and
then oh yeah yeah I saw Kira it's all
little Wonder Woman but I knew it was
Kira oh you knew right away yeah and
they're broke I loves carrot I'm so
tough Papa put her at hat and I'm nobody
thought he would let me recognize him if
they were G Papa does clean version of
gene pompa
I know right that's abuse what he does
for that happy Papa Qi Papa's hey looks
like you could just paint a wrestling
match ahead yes Tom papa was walking
ahead and his foes are suggested not
Robi Oh bro he put a little black head
to the side Jean cat goes to the side
cause it don't fit yeah
if his hat falls off you turned into a
snowman like five nights at Freddy's
give me something derail bro i'll Brad
we're gonna have we're gonna do it's
gonna be wild oh [ __ ] my neck Oh Maron
Mayer is gone Wow we're gonna break down
the stands
[Laughter]
ah Manos while I can't talk about it I
signed a non-disclosure I'm gonna put
you to [ __ ] headlock he was like oh
yes Sara I heard you bought a motorcycle
who told you that Oh Dean was just
talking about Dean it Oh
Dean went on a road trip to then they go
together with him that's the motorcycle
that [ __ ] you didn't already heard
himself on right how's he gonna break
Bota seat though he's alright he's
alright these great yeah no comic saw
him Kevin Christie saw him on the road
randomly just driving I think when he
got into that accident really stop of
course it was like is that Dean and then
he's like no way and then it was on four
times I mean Joe Medina pass me by
without broke down the feeling - he
didn't stop Tohono bro hopefully for
justice words I just start on your team
on the road the way called me at home
bro toy Ozzy
what's up fooling get to the hoarder Oh
next week tune in two weeks back
mother-in-law who will who told ex
mother-in-law who didn't like more tea
wouldn't know because she thought bro
when you cliff hanger out for it to flip
anchorman ten different type of [ __ ]
TV guy from different countries say HS
bicycle podcast what's your Instagram
again in your podcast a Comedy Store
podcast EJ Kerrigan Elinor Kerrigan
whatever EJ what's up well we didn't
even get to that guy they used to go up
on stage the Comedy Store and then
Panhandle afterward gzb wits with the
finger yeah but he changed his name to
something else now I know him as with
speech impairment man he's never go